greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
today your ruler and Savior wishes to
talk about trees
what better way to celebrate the birth
of life than going out into the woods
and killing an innocent plant dragging
it back to your home and decorating its
desecrated corpse you humans are sick
what is your peoples obsession with
decorating things from outside you are
embarrassing your tree dressing him up
like a prostitute the other trees are
looking in and laughing at your tree
calling him a whore for sap encrusted
lady of the night
luckily your tree cannot hear them
because he is dead much like my home
planet rest in pieces
why decorate your tree in the first
place where the pine cones not enough
for the supple berries that fed the
woodland birds or the hole that provided
comfort for the way with squirrel or I
have slaughtered millions on my home
planet of Krypton but your people are
just cruel
that's why in my news Argonian Republic
Christmas trees will be made out of you
the birds will decorate your fear filled
bodies with brightly colored trinkets
and lights and the wayward squirrel will
take comfort in your home and don't ask
me where he gets the nuts while I will
be dining on zodmas goose yes I don't
care if they die there are slow race
stupid one of them bit me in the ass
last week I punted him halfway across
the pond er than vaporized him with the
heat vision drawn from the MIT Yellow
Sun final sum of trees have no place in
bizarre Dhoni in people's republic of
houston humans lave trees with wayward
squirrels living in your rectum approved
deploy my bushy tail children this is
General Zod and you will kneel before me